et pour en parler nous sommes avec
morgane mouly vice-présidente syndicat
des jeunes biologistes médicaux bonsoir
morgan ellis merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france arnaud chiche
anesthésistes réanimateurs médical
fondateur du collectif santé en danger
bonsoir à vous également un hochet merci
d'être avec nous donc 47 candidats
vaccins sont en ce moment testé à
travers le monde plusieurs dizaine de
firmes pharmaceutiques sont engagés dans
la recherche c'est une course qui
suscite évidemment des appétits fabrice
di vizio le critiquer ardemment tout à
l'heure il faut au contraire se réjouit
de cette mobilisation morgan moulis
effectivement après bon bah on espère
vraiment que la france sera au rendez
vous comme vous l'avez dit d'abord en
attendant le feu vert de l'union
européenne pour vraiment valider un
vaccin je pense qu'au gouvernement on ne
peut vraiment pas s'en passer pour
garantir la sécurité puisque en bois
qu'aucun des problèmes et la logistique
mais le deuxième problème et il ya des
ions des français cette vaccination et
les derniers sondages ne sont pas du
tout en faveur de dunant vie des
français de se vacciner donc un double
défi pour le gouvernement avec
effectivement une première étape de
validation et de sécurisation du lac st
par région ce européenne du médicament
ouais la multiplication de ces annonces
father moderna c'est une bonne nouvelle
arnaud chichou vous rester méfiant c'est
plutôt une bonne nouvelle parce que il
ya quand même les infectiologues disent
bien que pour avoir une chance de
d'éradiquer locaux idée en tout cas de
pouvoir vivre avec lui il faudra la
stratégie vaccinale est forcément une
bonne stratégie
donc j'ai l'habitude de faire confiance
à mes experts après il est certain que
les annonces vont très vite et on a
besoin d'avoir la totalité des chiffres
on a besoin aussi d'avoir des
informations un petit peu plus précise
combien d'injection il faudra faire s
qui aura besoin de faire des rappels
est-ce que ce lac st protégera aussi
bien les personnes âgées ou les jeunes
on a besoin d'avoir les résultats de
toutes ses études
donc prudence un optimisme prudent pour
reprendre une expression très à la mode
alors en tout cas la france espère bien
ne pas louper le coche intra critiquée
sur sa gestion de la pandémie pour le
moment olivier verront le martèle notre
pays se prépare pour commencer une
campagne de vaccination débute 2021 je
vous propose d'écouter le ministre de la
santé
il y à un laboratoire qui a communiqué
des données intermédiaires suite à son
étude clinique en population générale
aux agences américaines et européennes
du médicament
on espère que d'ici trois semaines le
laboratoire en question files heures
aura donné la totalité de ces données
scientifiques qui permettront à ces deux
agences de faire une analyse rapide des
données et de nous dire si oui ou non on
peut commencer à instruire des dossiers
à l'échelle d'un pays en vue de vacciner
oui dans le même temps une distribution
du vaccin à biot nt kaiser est possible
cette année c'est ce qu'a indiqué tout à
l'heure le pdg de bio tech l'agencé
france presse
morgane ou lisse vous y croyez justement
cette campagne de vaccination des bulles
début 2021 vous êtes optimiste on ne
peut que d'être mais comme le dit le
ministre il ya des études qui ont été
faites mais elles sont encore
intermédiaire nous n'avons encore eu
aucun retour sur d'éventuels effets
indésirables
ce qui intéresse principalement quand
même les français donc on attend des
résultats définitifs des études
fortement concluante puisque le chiffre
qui a été un petit peu donnaient
ressemble plutôt un effet d'annonce
peut-être une petite aide aux marchés
financiers
on a donc on attend vraiment des
résultats scientifiques probants et à ce
moment là effectivement nous seront
favorables et on espère que le
gouvernement ce sera assez préparé pour
que dès que nous allions le feu vert
nous puissions voilà déployer cette
campagne de vaccination avec un maximum
d'adhésions des français et il est vrai
que qui vaccinera c'est encore une
question en tout cas nous les
biologistes médicaux qui a montré qu'on
était capable de faire les choses de
manière massive ces derniers mois sont
prêts à vraiment participer à la
campagne de vaccination avec tout le
matériel et logo qu à adapter pour le
faire alors il ya les autorisations
évidemment d
les autorités de santé en france mais il
ya aussi l'europe
je vous propose d'écouter un son de
stéphane bancel le pdg de modern art
c'est l'un des candidats qui fait la
course en tête également pour distribuer
ce vaccin écouter justement il parle de
ses problèmes de négociations avec les
différents pays européens
on discute avec beaucoup de pays
d'europe depuis le mois de mai mais nous
n'avons aucune signature de contrats
le vaccin est sur le point d'être
approuvé par les autorités sanitaires
européennes
ce serait dommage qu'aucun pays ne
puisse en disposer arnaud chiche est
assez édifiant cette interview du pdg de
moderna il explique que voilà il a
négocié et déjà dit léo l'a négocié ce
vaccin avec plusieurs pays l'italie
israël le japon mais voilà ça ça coince
avec beaucoup de pays d'europe dont la
france justement il parle lui même du
poids de l'administration européenne
c'est quelque chose dont nous français
il faut qu'on s'inquiète aujourd'hui
dont il faut qu'on s'inquiète je sais
que je sais pas madame je sais pas assez
c'est bon je sais pas c'est des
informations qui sont très anxiogène
pour les français je sais pas si c'est
très je sais pas c'est un chef
d'entreprise un c'est bien ça présente
en plus la probabilité de modène à toute
façon on sait que la bureaucratie elle
existe un en europe et en france
après bon j'espère que je compte quand
j'entends le ministre olivier ferrand il
a l'air quand même de tout faire pour
qu'on puisse mettre le pays en cas en
situation de vacciner une fois qu'on
aura des informations sérieuses sur ce
fameux vaccin et on se rassure qui aura
pas d'effets secondaires et d'effets
indésirables
donc en fait j'ai quand même envie de
suivre la dynamique de l'exit du
gouvernement sur ce point là et puis
peut-être que si le rap ou si ce
monsieur il a du mal à avoir des retours
directs et bien ya peut-être des raisons
il ya peut-être que c'est peut-être que
les données sont pas sont pas
suffisantes pour pour la france et qu'il
ya vous allez on va déjà très très vite
on va déjà très très vite on sait que
les procédures ont été accélérées et
bien écoutez on habite
je pense que vouloir aller vite
bien grillé toutes les étapes c'est
forcément pas bien il faut je crois que
pour qu'on puisse avoir une adhésion la
plus importante possible à ce vaccin
faut que les choses elles soient assez
limpide et bien moi j'ai quand même
envie de faire confiance dans les
autorités dans nos autorités parce que
vous voyez conférence de presse
aujourd'hui les infos sont claires en
commande les congélateurs et c'est donc
ça a l'air d'être voilà on veut aller
vite quoi donc dès qu'il y en aura un
qui donnera satisfaction je pense que la
france elle sera à dire elle sera à dire
est passé les bonnes commandes
alors c'est vrai qu'au marrant que la
campagne a été annoncée pendant quinze
jours avec astrazeneca et le fameux
vaccin chinois ordonnée par le roi
mohamed 6 à dubaï où la vie ensemble
revenu à la normale les restaurants sont
sont actuellement ouverts les me
renvoyer n'hésitent pas à se faire
photographier en se faisant vacciner
c'était le 3 novembre précisément
toujours le vexin chinois morgan moulis
à vous avez une réaction quand vous
voyez ce genre d'image ça veut dire quoi
comme le dit arnaud chiche c'est bien
les prudents en france on va on se donne
le temps il faut être prudent ou au
contraire voilà pourquoi il ya des pays
qui ont déjà débuté des vaccinations et
pas d'autres exactement c'est un choix
qu'ont fait certains pays de commencer à
vacciner avant d'avoir des résultats
définitifs sur les différents vaccins
candidats moi je pense que la france
fait bien être prudente
voilà comme l'a dit mon collègue au
vaccin a été fait très rapidement
voilà beaucoup plus rapidement que les
précédents vaccin pour d'autres
pathologies
donc il convient d'attendre vraiment les
résultats définitifs avant de commencer
à vacciner et je pense que le gars
russie la chine comme d'autres pays vont
peut-être un petit peu trop vite
voilà il faut quand même franchir les
étapes de sécurisation de vaccins de
garantie à la fois de la fiabilité et du
peu d'effet indésirable
petit à petit il faut vraiment respecté
toutes les étapes avant de vraiment à ce
moment-là déployer massivement le vaccin
même chose est sûre c'est que la
prudence votre présent semble partagé
par beaucoup de deux français
bonne nouvelle pour beaucoup d'entre eux
mais pour d'autres c'est plutôt de
scepticisme écoutez je pense dans tous
les cas ça conditionne la sortie du
confinement donc pour en finir avec ce
cirque je compte me faire vacciner le
plus tôt possible et j'espère que monde
en fera de même pour qu'on puisse enfin
en sortir efficace ou non peu importe
mais que ça finisse quoi pour l'instant
manche parce que c'est pas encore abouti
on cherche un vaccin à tout prix
rapidement
c'est pour ça qu'il est encore qui peut
être vraiment efficace
on n'en sait rien pour l'instant donc je
prendrai pas la v6 la session la presse
et chacun voit après ça tant qu'ils
veulent pas faire veux pas faire toi moi
je le ferai parce que je suis quand même
j'ai soixante six ans une personne dans
la fragilité ou de ma santé je le ferai
c'est très franco-français de pas mettre
ce mas de mettre le masque de tout de
tout refuser en première instance et
puis après tout le monde doit s'y faire
je pense que tout le monde va le faire
on a peu je pense qu'on n'a pas le choix
non plus arnaud aussi ce scepticisme
purement français fait quelque chose que
vous vous expliquez vous expliquez bien
c'est pas très nouveau ça on sait que
les français ils ont peu sont pas
forcément très favorable vaccin c'est
d'ailleurs un vrai problème
j'ai des parents qui va me faire
vacciner leurs enfants et puis c'est
comme ça qui a parfois des airs des
résurgences de deux maladies normalement
éradiquer qui sont catastrophiques
voilà après à la décharge des français
on peut pas dire que les deux crises qu
vite qu'on ait vécu en france se soit
passé dans la sérénité la plus totale et
en ce qui concerne les soignants en tout
cas je comme vous le savez j'ai fondé un
collectif de soignants qui réclame de
l'aide de l'aide à l'hôpital pour gérer
ça et peut-être qu'il ya un climat un
petit peu de scepticisme dans la
communication du gouvernement
il ya eu aussi quelques petits problèmes
ces derniers mois et ça a pu peut-être
faire douter mais je pense aussi que il
suffit de manière très pédagogique en
ayant une communication positive et
rassurante avant tout factuelle en
s'appuyant sur des choses sur des
résultats d'études sérieuses les études
qui ont été faites pour le vaccin
il s'agira de rassurer les français et
puis surtout de bien leur expliquer que
c'est dans l'intérêt de tous comme l'ont
dit certains de vos deux des gens qui
ont été interrogés c'est dans l'intérêt
de tous de pouvoir redémarrer l'économie
et que si le vaccin est retenu par nos
experts infectiologues comme étant une
piste pourquoi éradiquer ce virus et
qu'on reprenne toute une vie un peu
normal
je crois que on pourra alors laisser le
temps aux sites se faire à l'idée
et puis peu à peu conscience sinon on
verra bien qui ils se passent peut-être
pas grand chose et puis que d'un seul
coup ça donnera ça motivera tout le
monde
en tout cas il faut essayer de
communiquer positivement merci beaucoup
en tout cas à trouver de morgane money
cerneaux chiche d'avoir été avec nous en
direction est et france